[Music]
you think you can put your foot down
what are you gonna do with that I'm
gonna shoot at that Danny I think I can
help you with that
[Music]
as a private contractor you're
possessing a unique set of skills
[Music]
you said it was clear I said the front
was clear
ah front back right wrong anyway shall
we
I have another job for you so what we
got Greg Simmons the billionaire arms
dealer oh a lot very serious faces up
here and there you can't catch this fish
with conventional lures I'm sorry The
Lure being Danny Francesco
the movie star Greg Simmons favorite
movie star and how do we get him
blackmail
who's the guy very good carry on
the world needs you for your greatest
role yet who are you I'm your new
manager there's a sensitive and awkward
situation between you and your
sister-in-law I actually love my
sister-in-law it's done here you made
that quite evident when my remembrance
no need to be nervous no reason to be
nervous they're all the killers
you're an actor
would someone pinch me please is that
Danny Francesca what's next for you I'm
playing a mysterious self-made
billionaire he just described me shadow
me do whatever I do whatever I do to him
whoever Greg was buying from I was
amongst you last night
I can get inside of them
I hope you take them to dinner first
before you get inside of them
sexually
what happened he recognized your awesome
fortune that is a sexy name covers blown
what do I do the movie star's gonna melt
did you stopped any Francesca
worry about that
what are you gonna do with that I'm
gonna shoot at them Danny
so you weren't seen by anyone yes that's
a yes do you want scene by anyone yes or
yes you were seen by someone yes
[Music]
thank you